can you tell me about that story about
the man who had a stash of water
and
he felt like the main water source was
vitiated and so he didn't want to drink
from it
can you tell that story and the moral
behind it
yeah yeah
when the waters were changed
that's what's it called that's a sufi
story i think i don't know
it's origin
but that um
from what i remember is that uh
man was living in some kind of a
village or something and
and
and i don't remember
the part where he realized
that
the water is going to be changed when
they get changed people drink from it
they'll forget who they are
so he collected some of the water for
himself
you see
before it changed
and then people were drinking well they
all became sort of forgot who they are
he was still awake
but then you said that the point was
that
it was too much for him
well and then there is the quality yeah
how how is he going to live by himself
he he knows reality and everybody else
or i think reality is something else
so he chose to drink from the main
source afterwards uh yeah that's the
story's either he couldn't handle it the
need went and drank the new water
see i think this is part of what
is also can be dangerous about some
spiritual teachings is that there's the
social pressure that seems
unacknowledged because we use terms like
they couldn't handle it and then we
culturally have a norm that no you
should be able to handle so-and-so so if
you can't handle it there's something
wrong with you i constantly say this
that i'm not a truth seeker i'm a truth
seeker of how much i can handle and i'm
a coward
because i'm afraid of what could be true
but at the same time i used to feel
extremely bad about that i used to until
about three weeks ago when i say you
know what kurt
that's how you are that's it that's fine
just accept it i don't think that i'm
one of those people that's meant to have
that realization wow i think
i don't know about that you see
i myself see that many people
will be afraid to see certain truths
most people will be afraid of seeing it
would be terrifying for them
but i don't think that that doesn't make
me think i don't want to talk to them i
don't relate with them as equals and i
have friends
i mean many of my friends are
you know people don't not know me don't
understand don't know who i am you don't
see
me as me the way i know myself it's fine
with me
and i don't have a judgment of them
everybody is everybody has sort of
let's say a line of evolution for them
that is sort of
part of their destiny part of their you
know
well what's
happening in their soul and
people are different that way
so i mean you come back to this whether
there is a judgment whether there is a
hierarchy
you know right
like that
and it's true i mean spiritual teaching
sometimes they do have hierarchy of
different stages for instance
in the path but that that is in the path
itself if you are on the path on the
spiritual school there there are stages
and some teaching have stages something
you don't but that
doesn't mean the wise
the wise of that school are judging the
people outside of their school as you
know
unless then or anything like that you
see